in loksamawe aceh province nurul hida
and her six children are hungry and
increasingly desperate
her husband faisal has been in jail for
15 months and the family's source of
income is gone
my baby was only four days old when they
arrested faisal
sometimes we only eat twice a week
faisal was working as a fisherman when
he was arrested on a good day he would
earn about nine dollars
in june 2020 a group of 99 rohingya
refugees including 56 children were
stranded in waters near northern archae
their rescue by a group of indonesian
fishermen including faisal captured
global attention
but that wasn't the end of it faisal and
two other fishermen were convicted of
smuggling for their role in that rescue
my priority was the safety of the
rohingya children i just wanted them to
be safe and on land faisal says he was
approached by a rohingya man who asked
him to help rescue his family from the
sea
the three fishermen accepted a payment
of about two hundred dollars each
we didn't understand that we broke the
immigration law i hope my country can
forgive me
now as the fishermen await the result of
an appeal they spend their days in this
crowded cell
this is
prison where the fishermen are set to
spend the next four years of their lives
human rights groups say the sentences
are too harsh and should be reconsidered
many fishermen in aceh believe they
should help anyone in distress at sea
but that tradition also carries risks
there is a possibility where smugglers
make use of you know innocent fishermen
or
disinfectants a poor
fisherman
to
to achieve their goal
the government says the laws are clear
hopefully this will be a lesson for
other fishermen
so they won't do the same thing again
in december when a boat of rohingya
refugees arrived in waters near aceh the
fishermen did not told them to shore as
they have done in the past
we're trying to help as much as possible
without having it backfire on us
the arrests have unnerved them they are
more cautious about rescues now
as they wait for the release of their
friends they say they don't want to face
the same fate
jessica washington al jazeera aceh